it should be easy they can also be
healthy and here with some simple ideas
using some grocery store shortcuts to
get your picnic ready is registered
dietitian Abby sharp a B grade scholarly
thank you I know it's a little cool by
the water but it's going to be a good
day for a picnic okay and of course we
got Canada 150 comes out so weather
another great excuse for a picnic of
course okay so we're going to like some
easy swaps yeah yeah so typically when
you think about pasta salad you're
thinking about like lots of mayo like a
refined macaroni we can make it
healthier I love using this Capelli
ancient grains pasta it's got 12 grams
of protein and 8 grams of fiber so even
though we're going to make this vegan
and really safe to be outside in the
heat you're going to feel really
satisfied so instead of the Mayo we've
got some even honey mustard from the
store just a short about honey mustard a
little bit of olive oil and some lemon
juice here and that's just a really
simple vinaigrette that you can just
pull together with all your kind of
pantry staple okay so the mustard is
giving us a little zip a little flavor
lemons giving us some acidity exactly
and then we've got our pasta lots of
vegetables I've got some nuts in there
as well and some chickpeas for some
extra protein and fiber which is
fantastic so just throw that in there
put it in a little container you're good
to go okay and again you can do that
before you head oh you don't worry about
it spoiling in the heat that's the nice
thing is exactly there's no mayo there's
no dairy in it so it's very safe to be
outside okay now sandwiches our picnic
staple but instead of going for like the
really doughy baguettes with lots of
carbs I love these cute little flat out
folded they're 90 calories 7 grams each
of fiber and protein so again really
satisfying and again we're going to keep
this totally vegan and dairy-free so
these are great recipe for you know
bringing together your friends and
family who maybe all have different
dietary restrictions and things like
that but also it's just safer to be out
in the heat so got a little bit of
hummus going down I've got some sweet
potato toast
have you made sweet potato where did you
get this enough okay so all you guys do
a slice of piece of sweet potato yeah
then pop it in your toaster before you
head out the door and it's cooked and
it's ready to go
come on all right it's so easy just be
careful don't get it too thick around
cook or you can if it does you just put
it down another couple rounds as you get
less cooked through but yeah just don't
put your night for anything into the
the toasters going to get it up so a
little bit of avocado some sprouts go on
where you go wrap it up in some
parchment all right let's move on to
snacks snacks are so key so I just throw
a bag of chips into my cooking basket
but we can do better than that so I love
these little spring with snap peas for
man's because they're already washed
they're ready to go throw them in the
picnic basket with a tub of hummus happy
camper everyone loves that way healthier
way out here than chips and dip all
right before we run out of time those
drinks because you and I are big fans of
this right here yes I love the kombucha
because of course it's really fizzy it's
got natural sweetness probiotic benefits
almonds are great I love these kind bars
for just throwing into your picnic
basket so you got lots of variety for
your snacks and are ready to go yeah if
you do kombucha you don't have the sugar
it's a healthier exactly no sugar
there's no sugar added here this is the
kind Berkeley of five grams of sugar
almonds of course no sugar there's I get
the nut salted one so that there's no
extra sodium so getting all those
healthy fats beautiful enjoy your picnic
guilt free courtesy of a be sharp a B
thank you is calling
thank you have a great candidate they
are